[Music]
I spent the first 20 years of my career
in clinical research and academic
practice in Italy in 2003 I left the
hospital and I moved to the Pharma
industry and I have been in leading
roles in medical Affairs in Italy and in
Asia Pacific after that I moved to
Switzerland to Global product
development safety which is my current
function my focus is on the application
of digital Health technology allowing
Healthcare professionals to dedicate
more time to human aspects of medicine
that cannot be replaced by a computer
software or an algorithm digital Health
technology application in medicine is
still in its infancy and learning
opportunities are of utmost importance
to me I choose Stanford for many reasons
first Stanford University's a Knowledge
Center for digital Health technology
second the course program was
comprehensive and exactly addressing my
development needs third it was available
on Demand with no time zones issues I
like the balance between high quality
lectures with an outstanding faculty
case studies and exercises requiring
personal data mining I got very
interesting insights from the regulatory
perspective in the U.S where I spend
most of my time I'm definitely applying
many of the concepts I learned in this
course